fine fine you could say they eat too
much
mental health it's emotional eating okay
i'm using eighty percent sorry do you
think that eighty percent of people in
america have a binge eating disorder
then
god damn i i do think that probably the
percentage of people in america
disorder is a lot higher
one of the time guys
yeah i'm not saying saying 80 of people
in the in the usa do but i suspect
a lot more people in the usa if you look
at statistics maybe let's look at some
statistics
probably a lot more people in the us do
than in the uk
the obesity um i actually did look this
up so out of the ages of 24 to 25 to 34.
23 in the uk are obese
35 are overweight and 42 percent are
normal and
i can't it's so small the underweight
category that i can't even see it so
even in the uk but you can equally have
people who are of a healthy bmi that
actually have a very unhealthy
relationship with food
so yes i mean you can you can have a
good bmi and eat bad foods yes yeah yeah
that's possible but it's still a choice
the foods you put in your body are a
choice but
we're trying to make it better for
people not eating right like we can't
keep on doing that yeah i don't think
it's excuses but i just i can't i don't
think i can agree how heavily we're
putting it on the fact that it's a
choice but this is what i want
but this is what women do like honestly
anytime a man has a standard we shame
them for it and take accountability away
from women
no and this is this is i'm not saying
specifically you right but i'm saying in
general like the men say they want thin
girls or in shape girls and then the
body positivity movement comes there's
no but i'm saying there's no there's no
broken man positivity
yeah because it doesn't exist like we
take away accountability from women's
poor choices and even now like when
we're talking about hey it's a choice if
you eat too much and you gain weight
yeah it's like we're taking
accountability away from the woman by
saying it's not a choice but even women
even within the context of bodies right
if i'm i was born six foot so i'm i'm
happy i'm good but you were born sick
sorry
genetically i was jealous
i was genetically
i was genetically predisposed to be six
foot cool but if i wasn't if i was born
if i was meant to be five foot there is
no one here that would say to me women
should love you anyway women should go
for yourself women should find you
attractive they should you might say
that but most women won't so i think so
data fat guy
i have
would you and where is it
where is where is he now where is he now
i understand we have money back where i
left
i think i understand what you're saying
you're like there's some people for
example who might emotionally eat yeah
right so
we can we can say we understand why they
made the decisions they did in those
moments right because it may be to cope
with something right right so it's not
saying that we can't have compassion for
why they made those choices but at the
end of the day they did make those
choices yes right and that's what they
are worthy of love
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no you're taking it
no one is saying that they're not work
no one is saying that they're not worthy
of love
privilege is that maybe a thinner woman
would be well here's the thing i i when
it comes to thin privilege i think it
actually comes down to
beauty or attractive privilege because
chances are most people will probably
find you more attractive if you're on
the slimmer side than if you're obese so
you think it's a thing of attractiveness
and pretty privileged little not
necessarily well being being thin or be
being thin or being slim is a
contributing factor to how attractive
some people find you that's just the way
it is so who okay do you know what so as
pick a celebrity that you would say a
female celebrity that you would say
you're attracted to that megan good
right if megan good
was a size 20 tomorrow how big is that i
don't know how big it is
that's that's like older deal
that's bigger
that's big what we're talking about
she's she's obese she's obese okay she's
obese it's affected every part of her
for my knees has her face everything
okay cool
would that would that suddenly change
your level of attraction to her you just
said it's a contributing factor so of
course yeah because it's not just the
looks it's the self-respect
let me answer your questions
right do you think michael b jordan is
hot yeah right
he's like how would you rate him out of
10 physically seven okay
hold on hold on hold on michael b jordan
that's the most controversial thing
you've said a seven
a seven you should have chose that
doctor absolutely
that's not a ten i don't know
just l
okay so it's just elbow would you
physically would you rate him oh solid
eight solid a okay are you telling me
yeah yeah if you became obese yeah yeah
you would still wear him and ain't
physically
are you saying your attraction to him
would be the same
so him working hard to be in shape okay
he wouldn't it wouldn't cure
everyone
so the one who has the highest standards
yeah is the one that's saying if they
were fat they'd still be necessary
but the thing is the thing is the thing
is i just think a lot of times we lie to
like to women that are overweight and
say oh you're still worthy of love right
because it's not it's not that i say
like nobody will love you but the guys
that you want aren't going to be
interested in you because even bigger
girls they don't want to date bigger
guys look at lizzo her you feel like
they should do yeah
no i i think i think let's get them the
best results so you could either say a
lose weight that's probably the best way
right if liza lost weight she she'd be
cute like a lot of guys would be
interested and you'll say she's not cute
no not not i mean smash or pass lizzo
guys one two three
yeah okay no no guys guys if she was 120
pounds smash her past lizza one two
three
like if she was she she would be more
attractive yeah yeah like i'm saying
more guys would be interested i'm not
saying everyone but like but like she
could possibly get the results that she
wants right right right or we could lie
to her and say you're beautiful at any
size guys will still be interested but
maybe some but why would you say your
issue lies because it sounds like your
issue lies in okay cool if you're going
to be fat fine but it's like know it own
it and be okay with the limitations okay
so i have a couple issues with it i have
won the issue that we lie to women okay
so i don't i don't like telling girls
things that aren't true right so saying
like guys will still love you at any
size it's not true
that's not true some guy some guy
okay okay
guys the guys that you don't want will
want you so you can a guy
any guy that gets a lot of money has a
pretty model on his side
or maybe maybe she might not be a model
but she's in she's attractive right you
don't see any billionaires with obese
whale wives
so that's that's that's
statements it's not because because a
lot of times but we're talking about
exceptions and not the rule right you
might find a one-off and usually with
the if the rich guy does have a bigger
a bigger girl with him she got him young
and she gave him that loyalty young and
maybe she gained weight later that's so
unfortunate also we're talking about
observable reality we're not just you
know making blacks yeah we're talking
about observable reality we're not
saying that women who are bigger cannot
find love you can however as a result of
the fact that you're you're bigger
your pool of men has become smaller
unfortunately i'm not denying that but
where i have an issue i'm really not
denying that but where i have an issue
is pushing any narrative that makes it
seem like they're not deserving of the
man that they
but they aren't but they aren't you are
delivering it just do the work no no i'm
saying you're not deserving if you're
obese you don't deserve a guy that makes
six figures if you're
because they no obese they don't want
you why are we entitled to a man's time
affection and money because i'm big
no i'm saying
i'm saying no guys guys let me so what
i'm saying is that
you as you were not entitled nobody's
entitled to love you like so i'm not
going to go to a broke guy and say oh
you're you deserve love i'm going to say
no get a job
and and so on with the girls i'm not
going to say oh you deserve love i'm
going to say look i'm sorry if you want
those guys get on the treadmill
it's very similar because men and women
are valued for different things
yeah and so
i wouldn't say unfortunately because
it's a lot easier for a girl to just be
thin and pretty but it's easier and get
a banging body yeah
what if he has money and money is very
healthy money is money i would say it's
much harder to get money than to stay in
shape yep absolutely 100 so
if a guy if a guy wants to make 120
pounds right a year i think that's much
harder than losing 50 pounds
and